the white house confirms senior u.s
diplomats will boycott february's winter
olympics in beijing american athletes
will still participate but the move is a
high-profile protest over china's human
rights record
elizabeth palmer is in south korea
that's home of the last winter games
with the issues that the china's olympic
organizers are now facing
china has been spending billions on
state-of-the-art venues for what it
hoped would be a lavish and prestigious
olympics so this announcement comes as a
blow
the biden administration will not send
any diplomatic or official
representation to the beijing 2022
winter olympics and paralympic games
given the pierre scenes ongoing genocide
and crimes against
humanity and xinjiang and other human
rights abuses beijing's brand new
facilities were going to be empty of
foreign spectators anyway thanks to
kovid but the white house's decision has
infuriated the chinese
china's foreign affairs spokesman
replied with a warning
the u.s will pay a price for its
practices
you may stay tuned for follow-ups
in spite of a phone summit between
president biden and china's president xi
jinping last month relations remain
pretty frosty
the fact that the u.s is using the
boycott to highlight china's treatment
of the muslim uyghur people in its
xinjiang province
is bound to deepen the chill
six times in olympic history boycotts
have tarnished the games
two of the most famous were in 1980 when
the u.s and 65 other countries stayed
away from the moscow olympics after the
soviet invasion of afghanistan
four years later the soviets and their
allies retaliated boycotting the games
in l.a
as one of the key players who made sure
the 2018 winter games in pyeongchang
south korea went off with no political
hitches
governor moon soon choi told me the u.s
boycott will have a huge impact how much
of it is will be a blow to the way the
beijing olympics
are remembered in history
if the u.s delegation doesn't go to
beijing he said those games will not be
considered a success
so far the us is going it alone in this
human rights-based diplomatic boycott of
the beijing games the australians have
also said that they're not going to send
any officials but they claim that it was
a decision made
some time ago and it has to do with
covid security vlad
all right elizabeth palmer reporting
from south korea liz thank you as always